she's a beautiful person who I just
can't wait to share life with and the
feeling is definitely mutual former
bachelor Ben Higgins turned twenty-eight
on Wednesday and his fiancee lauren
Bushnell's celebrated by posting the
cutest Instagram ever the flight
attendant snapped a collage of three
Polaroid pics writing in the caption
happy birthday to this handsome man so
thankful I get to celebrate with you
today and forever ever since the
couple's engagement was revealed earlier
this month they've wasted no time
showing off just how in love they are on
social media silly selfies romantic date
nights and plenty of snaps flaunting
that stunning four carat ring safe to
say this couple defines hashtag
relationship goals up next for the
couple they're planning their wedding
here's what they told ET recently about
the possibility of tying the knot on TV
I think it's something we both are open
to I mean at the end of the day we just
want to get married and have a wedding
with our family and friends there and
celebrate